hello everyone and welcome to Round
seven of the 2020 Tata Steel masters
edition its former world chess champion
Vishwanathan Anand versus current world
chess champion Magnus Carlsen and it's
quite the thriller of a game so I'm sure
gonna enjoy it without further ado let's
check it out Vishwanath on Anand opens
with efore so c5 as expected caution
will most of the times go this as it
goes within his world chess championship
preparation night if three knight to c6
and now Bishop to b5 Annan goes for
Durazo limo and g6 in Kettering the dark
square bishop also one of Coulson's
favorite defenses we have castles by
Anand Bishop to g7 and now c3 numbing
the dark square bishop and also
preparing d4 we have Knight to f6
attacking efore and before advancing the
D pawn rook to e1 defending d4 pawn we
have castles by Magnus and now d4 so we
have a six and here Bishop captures and
c6 and Bishop to f1 are known moves in
the position however Anand goes for
blush of the d3 and it is already as of
muevate that we have a completely new
game so Carlsen strikes in the center we
have d5 and now II five and here across
and spent over 20 minutes on this move
probably deciding whether to go Knights
to e4 or Knights to e8 in the end he
decided 498 now and undecided okay now
it's time to grab bonds D captures on c5
so if he can consolidate if he can play
b4 and keep the structure then it's it's
it's a solid pawn so Bishop to g4 Magnus
immediately goes for one of the
defenders of the e4 pawn if he can
eliminate that he can win back the pawn
so Bishop back to E - and here you have
to decide whether you wanna capture
right away or maybe not here the problem
is if you capture here then Bishop
captures Knight captures on e5 you allow
Queen captures on d5 so you haven't
really want anything back
Knight to d3 now attacking the rook and
here you would see Ruby one Queen
captures on d5 Bishop captures and now
only now knife captures on c5 winning
back at the bond so the material is
equal and it's pretty much everything
straight down so instead Magnus goes for
night to c7 before going for this adding
one more defender to the d5 pawn and
here you could go Bishop the effort to
further defend the e5 pawn but then 96
goes after the bishop ended the CC pawn
so you either go back and you lose this
point or you go to e3 and then you lose
this point so instead a nun chooses the
best defense well defense of the pawn
Knight bTW - now you simply have no
means of removing one of the defenders
and everything works works nicely now so
what can you do here Magnus goes a5 he
prevents b4 he doesn't want White's the
cement his pawn on c5 and now h3 asking
we do want to capture them I'm just
gonna capture back with the night and
end all this well so Magnus goes back
with the Shabak to c8 and now back to d3
opening up the the rooks defense of the
e5 pawn also possible was Bishop to f1
for some reason the engine prefers it
probably as the bishop on d3 walks the
Queen's influence on the D file but who
knows I always say those engines are
tricky bastards
so Knight back the East sets by Carlson
and now comes Knight to b3 the c5 pawn
is attacked so he just defends it with
Knight to b3 and now Magnus pushes a4
again removes the defender of the c5
pawn Knight bd4 and here Magnus grabs
the pawn back the nightcap force on c5
and now Bishop to c2 so again the
material is equal and now it's time to
figure out whether this be 5 point is is
a weakness or strength so Queen to a5 by
Magnus now developing the Queen I still
have to decide what to do with with what
to do with the bishop here with the ship
to d2 now putting the bishop in front of
the Queen and rook to d8 defending
defending against c4 with a tactic if
see for now then you can move the Queen
and the d5 pawn is protected but you
could go for further with this night b5
kick the Queen back
Queen b6 now now if if characters then
queen can capture on b5 but still see
captors on d5 Queen captures on b5
captures your characters here and it's
again everything traded down not much to
go here on and also after this rook to
b8 move
you could try b4 right away but then
again everything just gets traded off
this captures you can capture with the
knight Knight captures Bishop captures
and this is also one of the
possibilities but before that island
goes Queen to c1 so what happens now
Magnus goes back Knight the e6 or the he
doesn't want b4 now to come with with an
attack against both the Queen and the
knight but Magnus push on and pushes it
either way so b4 and here if you play a
cap for some b4 on pasanda and
everything just gets straight and Knight
captures with an attack on the Queen B
captures a captures captures captures
you can go for even more characters
captures captures and now now going
after the the e5 pawn would have six
characters captures and you get this
position again completely equal material
ah pretty much pretty much equal ish so
Carlsen not interested in that he goes
back Queen to c7 prefers to keep the
tension now comes Knight captures on c6
b captures and Bishop to e3 now grabbing
hold of the dark squares and c5 now you
don't want to keep this backwards pawn
there so c5 b captures Knight captures
and the Queen to a3 by Anand going after
the knight on c5 Knight back the e6 and
now rook bait
rook a to be won and I don't played this
fairly quickly as yeah black doesn't
really have any threats against the pawn
here and even if you could win upon you
you don't you you almost never want to
give up your darks for a bishop because
you just create a lot of dark square
weaknesses around the black King but
here it doesn't even win a pawn after
captures captures and captures you lose
the e7 point and okay Queen captures on
c3 but now Bishop to h6 is very strong
so again you will you will feel the the
holes left behind around the black king
of course you cannot capture because of
Queen f6 followed by mate
of course mate will be possible because
the rook captures night and and so on
so after this row kb1 d4 by Carlsen so
what do you play here we had Knight
captures on d4 and now
again what do you play here now will
Magnus played Bishop character 75 the
problem with knife captor son d4 and
Bishop chakras on d4 is that you cannot
give up at the rook for two bishops if
you could that'd be great but you can't
because if captures captures and
captures now you have a winning move for
Anand even pause the video and try to
find this winning move in a position
that never actually happened well I'll
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations it's it's a beautiful
move you have to use the D whole board
to find it and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show first Queen to f3
Queen to f3 with an attack on the rook
force the rook to move this is a if you
thought about the roof to c1 first that
doesn't work you first have to kick away
the rook from the defense of the bishop
because here you cannot go rogue b8 and
you cannot defend the rook so you have
to move the rook let's say we're OK 7
and now this now this is completely
winning if you move the Queen you lose
the bishop so you can play Queen f5 but
here is here is the threat rook to b8
and that there is no good move here
where Anand would just win here if if
captures then captures with check you
have to give up more material captures
here and well after looking moves and
now you just end the variation with
white being up a whole look so
unfortunately for black this is not
possible Bishop characters on e5 is
played and now Knight the b5 by Anand
you could go for Knight captures here
now but uh none prefers to keep the
tension and he he wants to keep his
advantage going he's up upon after all
so he wants to make it happen the only
problem for Anand is this has only moved
27 and Anand is on 11 moves if sorry 11
minutes on the clock whereas Magnus has
something over 15 minutes on the clock
that's okay the Queen is under attack
Queen to c6 and then now comes rook the
b4 look the before this is a move played
with the idea that he wants to play
Bishop to e4 attack the Queen and win
material however there there was a
slightly more precise way to do this
Bishop to h6 is even better because you
already threatened butter to e4 now
because the regards it and also there's
the
the route captures an e5 so to avoid
this you can go back with the bishop
because of just Bishop to e4 so you have
to play Bishop to d6 attack White's
Queen and then queen bee to and well the
game continues but with a lot more
pressure from from white Bishop to e4
still a threat and it's a it's a very
nice position for white but okay now
Anand went for rook to be four instead
it also comes with a double threat
Bishop to g4 and also just winning the a
for pawn so here Magnus goes Bishop to
b7 now he invites Bishop to e4 which
Anand does we have Queen to d7 Bishop
captures on b7 Queen captures and now
rook captures on a four so on and grabs
a pawn and now he's going to will try
and you know nurture it to become
something more and clockwise Anand is
now on eight minutes on the clock
whereas Magnus is somewhere around 44
minutes so Bishop to f4 yeah and it's a
it's a very good idea as since if the
bishop is captured Knight captures runs
into some problems because you cannot
capture the night the Queen would hang
and also there is mate threatened here
so it would be very unpleasant if if f3
Queen d5 again with threats of Queen d2
fall by Queen G to mate here black would
definitely be better so here on unjust
rates we have rook captures rook
captures and the Queen to b3 Magnus
captures an e3 Bishop captures rook
captures and now Knight to f4 with the
threat of checkmate
so would you play here island goes rook
to f3 and it it is the best decision
better than making holes in front of the
in front of the White King so rookie
free basically paralyzing the night
since the f7 pawn falls if you move the
knight we have Queen D for now by Magnus
and the now King to H do not allowing
any checks along the the back rank and
here it's moved 36 on in this below 5
minutes on the clock and now a g5 is the
move well the engines prefer just
keeping that night there and you know
start bringing the other pieces into the
game however Magnus goes for Knight to
d5 instead so what happened
now well we have c4 yeah okay you cannot
push a four since both the rook and the
Queen guard da pond but you can start
pushing the sea pond which is what unand
us we have Queen to e5 check provoking
more weaknesses we have g3 and now
Knight back to f6 we have a three and
then out comes Knight back to e4 so
again what do you do here we have Queen
to c2 now adding another defender to the
to the f2 pawn and also as supporting
the C pawn now you will start pushing it
and here f5 is definitely a possibility
again if you want to cemented that
knight on e4 and then see where to take
it from there
Magnus decides for Knight to g5 instead
we have worked the e3 pushing the Queen
back Queen to c5 and now h4 pushing the
knight back of course Knights the e6 and
now Queen e2 again defending the c4 pawn
you cannot move the knight because of
rook captures and e7 so what what can
Carlsen play we have roped the c8 going
after the c4 pawn and now rook c3 just
defending and here h5 by Carlsen and
forgot to mention we have already
reached time control so Anand is no
longer under pressure King to g2 and now
kink the f8 by Magnus we have Queen to
e4 and now King back to g8 here Magnus
just has to wait and see what what
island will come up with Queen to d5
here Anand offers a queen trade but
Magnus of course is not interested just
yet Queen to b6 and now a for da for
pawn starts marching forward with Queen
to a6 going after the a for pawn and
here we have a very interesting position
so even pause the video here and try to
find what what would you play with white
here well while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who founded
congratulations on being an excellent
strategical tactician and for those of
you who just want to enjoy show
Anand played c5 here he gave up the a
four point to start pushing your sleep
on by the rook that III was really
really awesome here point being that if
you capture the pawn now then you just
lose the rook captures on e6f capture
screen captures with
Chuck King cast the move Queen capture
some see it your upper piece that your
past bone is defended and everything
works out and if you don't go for the a
for pawn then by rook to e3 you have
just well you've successfully defended
the pond while always keeping this an
option
the problem is black cannot go rook c5
if rook c5 trying to kick the Queen away
again a capture night and you've removed
the defender of the rook while
threatening to capture the Queen so if
ro captures here again you capture here
and Europe a knight and even if you
don't if you try rugby eight it's still
the same thing just remove the defender
of the rook
so roof to e3 is a very powerful move
which which should have been played but
okay it's also a possible idea c5 with
Queen captures on a4 and now c6 the
ponies is marching forward we have rook
to b8 now pushing the Queen back and now
Queen to c4 offering a queen trade with
Queen captures and c4 route captures on
c4 and now rook to b8 attacking the
knight provoking c7 on and of course
pushes c7 wheel rook the c8 and now once
again feel free to pause the video and
what would you play here just you know
just a nice question so for those of you
who have found the move I'm just going
to show you you have superhuman strength
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show
Allen played rook the c1 and it was in
this position that the players agreed to
a draw however there was a move that
that could have made a lot of things
possible and that's a rook to be four so
congratulations to everyone if you found
it point is that rook the before packs a
lot of poison to it because it prevents
black from activating any of the pieces
the roof you cannot move the rook the
knight well you kind of need the night
at the guard upon the the
straightforward threat of just captures
you just play rook c4 and you're gonna
win the exchange either you lose the
night or you capture here and capture
here with Czech and it's the this will
be winning for white so after book the
before the problem for Carson is that
King to f8 is impossible King to f8 is
impossible because
of a beautiful tactical shot Knight to
d6 it attacks the roof of course the
route cannot move because you bring your
Queen into the game so you have to
capture here but now comes Rock check
King has to go back and now Knight the
ei twit check so that's why rook to b4
is is really a superhuman move and well
after rook the before the only proper
way to continue the position is came to
g7 and then after King to f3 the engines
give that you have to give up the
exchange here for example with Knight
captures on c7 and try and hold this the
problem is if you continue playing
actively King to f6 then you get rook
the c4 and this rook to see for another
superhuman move saying that ok this pawn
remains here you will never move your
look and you are not moving anything
here if King gave 5 trying to shield of
the White King from reaching the
position if you do nothing then the
White King will just go up the board and
win the game so you have to shield from
that King III now and again you don't
have many options here you have to play
something g5 characters captures and
well it's just just a bad bad position
for black the engines give this as
completely winning for white so the only
good variation after rook the b4 would
be really king here King to f3 and now
to actually capture this it's too
dangerous so a pawn rook see for CalPERS
captures and now with the Knights to d6
try and try and hold this or or f6 for
that matter it's a three against four
rook against the knight so would would
the knight be able to hold this well
that's that's a question for the ages
but there was a possibility so maybe on
and thought about it maybe he he was
again very low on time here maybe he
decided that even if he calculated all
that out maybe he decided that that
position was still a draw who knows me
maybe but yeah
looked to be for definitely a lot of
poison to it so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Ken Thompson
Christopher Gordon Frank combs a
Salvatore a John Brennan and a crystal
day for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
Steel and checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
chess world as there are a few more
games that are very exciting from this
runt there are still being played while
I'm recording this so we'll see what
happens there so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your Saturday